[Music]
we begin with Demi Lovato's recovery
yeah a lot of new questions tonight
because Demi woke up this morning still
in the hospital
6 days after her drug overdose and one
surprising person has been constantly by
her side I knew I loved them when I met
him a source tells e.t Demi Lovato's ex
Wilmer Valderrama has been a constant
source of support for her since her
overdose whoa he visits Demi every day
he can and has spent hours with her and
her family
we're told the singer has been
experiencing nausea and fever in the
hospital but getting better and
recovering she and Wilmer split in 2016
after six years together was exactly
when she needed me to love her it last
year Demi posed for a pic with Wilmer at
a party and wrote best of friends no
matter what I'm pretty sure that I'm not
doing anybody that compares to him
[Music]
tomorrow is one week since Demi's
overdose addiction expert dr. howard
samuel says it's been an unusually long
hospital stay we don't know exactly the
drugs that demi was using but for her to
be in the hospital for six days sort of
suggests to me that maybe they're
detoxing her off of opiate or a benzo
such as xanax or Valium and they didn't
want to release her until she had gotten
these drugs out of her system as for
what's next for Demi and Wilmer well
listen to what Demi told Kelty last year
I value my time by myself now and I
value my time with my friends but then
seeing all this footage of you guys I
was like I kind of want them at the end
is that like still a possibility can we
hang on to that for like a few more
years you never know what's gonna happen
and I don't know what's gonna happen
[Music]